an unexpected meeting with an old friend
in the worst of circumstances who are
you a Bittersweet Escape
and the most painful Choice one can make
where do my duties lie my parents with
my children
no good or bad decisions just difficult
ones
NHS Dr Iman escaped days of brutal
Warfare on an Irish evacuation Mission
with her children forced to leave behind
her sick father and elderly mother after
giving up on the British Embassy
the guilty Australia's
is unbearable
and you just think to yourself
should I have left should I have stayed
behind
he just angers me so much that
beautiful Sudan with its Beautiful
People is being
governed by boys with very dangerous
toys
the UK government has begun evacuating
British citizens but many of the
thousands Left Behind have already begun
the dangerous journey to Egypt
the trapped NHS doctors WhatsApp chat
group and as of now there are 79
participants
there everyone received the message
about what the government had said that
today it will happen but many of them
have already moved
and as they prepare to leave news of
another loved one killed in the violence
I'm thinking
lucky we're lucky we got out
so that is a country of over 45 million
people well where do they go where do
they stand
they have no luggage to check in only
traveling with the clothes on their back
everything else home country and
Community left behind
us Sky News Djibouti